timée couteau j'ai une mauvaise nouvelle
de condos n'est pas mauvaise à ce point
c'est moi tu te suis non mes parents jj
son passage à londres et ils vont venir
me voir au les parents les barreaux
américain mais quand maintenant oui ils
me l'ont dit et je t'ai rien dit et je
croyais qu'ils annuleraient comme d'hab
mais c'est raté on attend maintenant
maintenant maintenant maintenant tu
devrais mettre un pantalon
je suis désolé je suis désolé il sort
que j'ai juste où j'ai évoqué un truc
dans ton genre mais rien de très précis
oui ils sont assez conservateur alors
fait pas sans talent
bien oui tu tu pourrais gagner un peu de
temps je joue partout